ether 2015 was a pretty spectacular show
all up and while many of us work front
and center to see uncharted 4 fallout 4
and Star Wars Battlefront I thought I'd
take this opportunity to show you some
of the awesome trailers that you might
have missed out on Dark Souls 3 wasn't
really on anybody's radar given the very
recent success of From Software's of a
big game blood-borne nonetheless the
announcement trailer was wonderfully
gloomy in typical souls fashion although
the series is huge you could be forgiven
for missing this little two minute
trailer stuffed in-between other game
presentations at the Microsoft press
conference the doom and gloom ended with
the image of a huge untiring foe and the
rumor mill is already rolling into
overdrive speculating on what the next
installment will have in store
Microsoft wasn't done there though they
also had a sweet trailer to announce
recore a new game from Keiji Inafune a
and some of the developers behind
metroid prime the beautiful trailer
which takes place in the desert
showcases protagonist jewel and her
sidekick alongside a number of creatures
who appear to function by a cause said
cores appear to represent the essence or
soul of a creature and can be rehomed
they also come in both good and evil
form as helpfully represented by their
blue or red color we're told that the
story will revolve around the character
of Jewel and her robot companion Mac who
can be transferred into other forms if
you watch the Ubisoft press conference
then you definitely caught the trailer
for southpark the fractured but whole
for the rest of you though it's
definitely worth checking out
in probably the funniest trailer of the
show South Park did an awesome job of
warming up the crowd with lines which
included now available for pre-order
yeah everybody pre-order like that's a
good idea
Cartman also called the previous game
the stick of truth quote Bailey even an
RPG the combat sucked
adding we won't settle for anything less
than a 9.5 from GameSpot even though
it's not being developed by Obsidian
Entertainment again we can hopefully
assume that this one will follow in the
acclaimed footsteps of the previous game
although there were plenty of rumors no
one was a hundred percent sure what
Killzone dev guerrilla games we're gonna
pull out at the bag this year whilst we
suspected it would be graphically
impressive it turned out that gorilla
had more to show than just a pretty
trailer horizon zero dawn is one of
those game names we'll just accept for
what it is and hope it makes more sense
later on but even if it doesn't and this
trailer already had heads turning it
told a fascinating story of the rise and
fall of civilizations and fearsome
robotic beasties but the top at a loss
gorilla gave us a live gameplay demo to
show us that the game was the real
horizon was a pleasant surprise which
helped Sony set the press-conference bar
high finally I have to give this last
spot to my personal favorite trailer of
III 2015 and that's the surprisingly
touching unravel in a slew of
conferences filled with explosions
gargantuan enemies and epic world
unravel set itself apart with a little
wooly protagonist called Yanni and his
seemingly small-scale adventure
the charming puzzle platformer warms the
hearts of even the most jaded of games
earners in the audience and provided a
refreshing respite in the EA press
conference
sure we were emotionally manipulated by
a real-life Johnny doll and some
deliberately emotive background music
but it was great to see EA takes some
time out from showcasing battlefront and
its sports titles to highlight something
totally left of field those were five of
my favorite trailers which you might
have missed out on but be sure let me
know down in that comment section which
trailer from e3 2015 was your favorite
and bye I'll catch you again next week